welcome to this video I'm playing Chavo
from Spain let's see this is solian
going for this funky Bishop d7 line it's
quite interesting not a very a very
well-known line but it is is a playable
alternative ok mhm I really don't know
it I'm just saying playing this by M hmm
yeah but probably maybe you can just
play it in this typical Slovenian
fashion okays he's going for a very
aggressive set up maybe Bishop d7 is a
move you don't really want to make here
maybe
b5 yeah there is probably a move like
eff this can be can be a problem quickly
opening up the default don't like that
very much yeah however I don't I don't
think I'm so quickly mated on the
kingside b5 before now let's see yeah
very often Queen 85 and b5 don't really
fit on mixed mix so well away is very
quick
yeah I really turn I really didn't want
to go to e8 and that's not good but ok
g5 is hanging with the check that's
that's not I mean okay it's have it
still chattering okay I probably I just
happened I probably must take that it is
of course not without any without too
dangerous but but still this should f6
here probably
yeah I wanted to go Queenie 52 and block
it but he prevented that probably a wise
choice still it's not it's not a quick
made or anything you 505 opens up the
bishop quite substantially Queen g2g six
still ok yeah ok I want to have the c5
square for the Queen yeah we can do that
at least the serve take some time yeah
there should be six a thought
taking here is probably not a good idea
wow this I didn't didn't consider at all
okay I need to move at some at some
point Wow group takes you five that's
really a really a big problem rook takes
d5 I mean
and night f5 is also problematic you
know rook takes rook to eight maybe this
is still okay you can take with the pawn
you can play night Evan either five is
stronger threatening nighty 700g
seven-time warning
yeah why he just blundered g5 but the
position was still so dangerous that it
was more than difficult to play it was
lost anyway I cannot check a lot defend
the position simply some game possible
black resigns yeah it was it was such a
dangerous position I mean this is just
blunt Jeff course but it's still very
hard to defend with the pieces being
misplaced yeah maybe yeah the computer
is pointing out the idea to play Queen
d8 and Bishop f4 that's that something
but um yeah probably here it's already
it's already a compensation the G file
and I don't have very well placed pieces
Queen edge fire fists the computer
suggestion now this is probably somewhat
better of it yeah it's not it is better
than you have I was thinking okay I'm
giving a pawn back but coordinate my
pieces this is just very strong look g5
after that basically I'm basically
busted I guess yeah that's very strong
rookie five or fe5 in the right moment
is just just killing black yeah it
wasn't a good a good opening line I
probably maybe I should should play 96
eng six this is i think how it is
usually done if Bishop c4 is being
played here okay thanks for watching